I just got like sick from the Airbnb
right oh oh yeah he got like a fungal
infection yeah he thinks he got it from
the Airbnb it could be a fungal
infection yeah like where I think in the
sheets
it was it was a very old house very
traditional Japanese house just in the
middle of nowhere oh yeah I remember I
remember a daughter telling me about
that and you had issues finding a proper
doctor yeah this happens a lot though
every dermatologist he went to was like
damn
I don't know what that is
like we I just had a similar [__]
experience with Sydney actually uh
because one day uh Sydney just had like
a massive like a massive massive bruise
on her leg right it was uh it was that
night we went out was she okay yeah
she's fine she's fine it's okay so my
biggest worry was that it was a blood
clot or internal bleeding or something
because I'd like she had not like hit
like that part of her body at all we're
just the bruise just appeared
um and so we're like rushing to try and
find a doctor and I don't know if this
is a Japanese thing but it's just is
there just like a general practitioner
that you can go to like a general okay
store clinics right yeah there's clinics
that specialize in certain parts of the
body and you need to just know this
problem is this particular Clinic yeah
yeah yeah so nice so I'm like what
doctor do I go to because you can't just
go to a general practitioner who can
refer you to the specialist right you
have to go to the specialist
unfortunately I ain't a [__] doctor
so I'm I'm just I'm we were just like
kind of guessing so uh we uh tried we
tried flow uh we tried going to a bone
doctor right and uh because they kind of
like have some specialized
the bone doctor I know I know there's a
word for it but like Orthopedics or the
author something something author
something author something I don't know
uh and you know they uh they looked at
the bruise and they were like that's bad
that looks bad let's do some checks and
they said they did some checks
um and then they uh did like an
ultrasound of it and everything and they
were like yeah we can confirm that it is
not a blood clots or internal bleeding
but we don't know what it is and we were
like can you refer us to somewhere where
we can get like a check to maybe try and
find out what this is and they will like
don't know and I was like okay so I've
just I've just discovered like from
going to the the doctors for like
certain small things where it's just
like if you don't know what it is yeah
immediately or you don't know the
particular Clinic like if you have like
an ear infection right for example which
I I had a couple of years ago then that
you can just go to an ear eye and throat
specialist right yeah you can usually
get it fixed up but if it's something
like really like open-ended like like an
unknown bruise yeah you're better to
just go to like a general like big
hospital really really because if you go
to a big hospital then they have
everything for the most part whereas
small clinics usually only specialize in
like certain possible qualities and you
have less equipment so if you just go to
a big a big hospital then immediately
you know they'll be like all right so
what's the issue okay well then go visit
visit this clinic in this building is
that what you ended up doing so I guess
second part of the story next day we
were like I'm still really worried about
this massive bruise and then like
another one had appeared the day after
as well
um so we were like let's let's just go
to like a much bigger Clinic uh Hospital
uh so we so we went to one and you know
they had a reception and they asked oh
who do you want to see
um and so the doctor
we were like we want to see a doctor and
uh they were like okay what's the issue
and then you know we explained the Brews
we showed them pictures
um and they were like I don't know if
you should see the dermatologist or like
the bone doctor again and and I was and
I was like unfortunately I'm not a
medical professional just try one and
let's figure it out yeah yeah just go
from there yeah yeah so so they were
like so I was like okay we explained the
symptoms more uh concretely and uh then
uh we also got told that okay if you
have like further issues then they can
maybe refer you to like another
department or something like that
um so they were like let's start you off
in the bone doctor first because
[Music]
because they can do more
um they can do more checks than what we
had in the other thing yeah yeah for
sure
um and so we we queue up uh and it's uh
it's a three hour wait
it is it is uh it is it is a three-hour
wait all right to uh and we're like
don't worry Sydney we're in a hospital
we're gonna we're gonna get the more
we're gonna get the checks that we need
don't worry about it Sydney don't worry
about it Sydney
um so a weird thing so this this end up
being like a church hospital or
something like that because there were
like sisters in the place like kind of
like nuns working in the place
where the [__] hospital did you go to
this kind of hospitals
um so after after this like three hour
long Waits uh we she goes in to see the
doctor and then uh she explains her
symptoms and the doctor's like okay I
can't check it right now and she was
like why can't I check it well uh and he
explains well this this is like a
special hospital and we have to be very
polite
um so you know since since you're since
you're since you're a girl we're gonna
get one of like the sisters to you go
are you kidding bro I think he went to
the wrong Hospital right away
I want to go to this hospital just to
see what the [__] up yeah so so
basically so basically she had to go to
another room where like the nurses would
cover up her entire body except for like
that one except for that one area so I I
had no idea like church hospitals were a
thing but like this this was like this
is like a weird experience for me as
well
um so that happened and then the doctor
looks at it and he just goes I don't
know what it is let's have an x-ray and
I was like why why are we uh why are we
doing an x-ray for a bruise maybe it's
something I don't understand I I don't
understand
um and so and so we do the X-ray wait
another like half an hour 45 minutes for
this for this x-ray sure uh at this
point we've been in the hot the hospital
for about four hours
uh and so uh we they do they do the
X-ray wait for the results go back in
and they were like yeah we don't know
what it is uh do you want to try that do
you want to try the dermatologist and I
was like how long is the wait for that
and he's like it's the same process as
uh the process for this department and I
was just like Sydney how do you feel
right now is this is this
life-threatening like would you say how
do you feel to somebody like please tell
me you're fine
ever get started
it's uh we we never found out what it
was is it still there it's it's healing
right now uh so my rule of advice go to
an actual Hospital next time maybe don't
go to whatever the [__] this church
hospital is yeah I mean we uh it's a
part of part of the issue was we tried
to find we try to find like an
English-speaking Hospital right uh so
that was like the closest one to our
vicinity that luckily geeksplus had
found for us yeah yeah um so it was it
was it was a proper hospital just just
just Spotlight so he also signed up to
Scientology
that's cool yeah were they just like
using a big stop and a video idea yeah
so two for one so in the so in the end
uh luckily Sydney has a local doctor in
the US and she sent a picture and she
was like oh you probably have a low
platelet count and I was like damn
that's uh that that took uh how long not
to like [__] on all of Japan because I
don't think I do that enough yeah I've
heard a lot of horror stories about like
hospitals and doctors and stuff here and
I've I've just had generally just meh
experience I mean it's better than the
UK because I can only see someone here
which is someone on the same day yeah uh
I remember when I when I filmed the uh
uh when I [__] up my knee on the uh
special the oh oh yeah yeah I went to a
a leg Clinic that specialized in it was
mainly elderly people there and I was
yeah I was like the only person who's
like under 80 there and um now that you
mention it I had this weird memory where
they made me
they wanted to scan my leg and they
wanted me to take my pants off and they
gave me like these shitty gym shorts and
I went in this room that was clearly a
used to be a PD and a pediatrician
office because it had just like
cute little lion things all around the
wall like sent out of like a horror
movie like the stereotypical kid
hospital room yeah yeah I'm just sitting
there with these weird ass old shorts
and I'm like this is weird and I just
got to go on the things they propped my
leg up not with like some kind of no not
that it needs to be anything it's
amazing but it was something like a can
of something it's how they propped my
leg up to take the X-ray I was like it's
like a can of peaches or something like
what the [__] is this where am I where
am I getting scammed is this like perks
of knowing Japanese because I've had the
most normal hospital experiences I
probably also had um I went to uh an
English-speaking doctor and I I go there
and uh we rock up and uh obviously he
knows it's in English actually I did the
appointment like it was all it was all
English yeah I rock up and I go in and
uh he sits there and he's like uh what
is uh wrong and I go
oh um I think my throat hurts and he
goes
throat throat nanny
I was like what I was like
oh no no no sorry no no it's like nodo I
was like man this man doesn't know what
throat is in English I'm [__] I'm
[__] I don't know any English
he's a doctor and he did he was
especially in English was what is wrong
and then after that yeah he's like yeah
I knew when he said what is wrong I was
oh no oh no and then he didn't know what
throat was in English and I was like I'm
[__]
what are you gonna tell me exactly yeah
so it was just kind of like really
painful I hope I said everything correct
and I hope he got it it turned into a
Japanese one because I put more Japanese
than he spoke English yeah I was like oh
[__] Jesus Christ yeah yeah so it's
funny like most countries I've been to
it's like a different Healthcare
experience you know uh you know in
America you got to mortgage your second
house yeah to go to the hospital but you
get it uh in England uh you got to wait
till next Century to get a appointment
that's free and in Japan you kind of
play Dr Bingo where you self-diagnose
yourself and hope you go to the right I
can't believe Japan got your fight
[Laughter]
yo you speak English and you can get me
fixed up that's a double like basically
if you get if you get sick in Japan hope
to God that it's something that you can
self-diagnose yourself trying to pay the
wedding in Japan you can definitely pay
for better quality and faster service
and stuff hey how much have you wailed
on doctors
yeah I've completed this entire area bro
like I've seen them all oh because
mailing recommended me uh this uh an
English dentist and I started asking
around I realized almost every Foreigner
I know goes to an American dentist yeah
yeah or American train is that like that
I trust the Japanese dentists dude
Japanese dancers are scary I've heard I
heard they stay because I obviously the
way you train is very important yeah uh
and you know obviously people from the
UK we get we get memed a lot for uh
having bed yeah yeah yeah the joke
Everly I know you love your British
jokes but American dancers know what's
up I'll give them credit yeah they have
the best [__] teeth like they do they
do yeah they do too good because they
floss yeah yeah you can go to a lot of
yeah you can go a lot of English
speaking in American it might be a
Japanese dentist but it'll be like
American trained and American practice
right yeah it's very common it's a lot
of them how many dermatologists did you
guys have to go through and I I never
knew how that situation got solved did
you ever find out what it was never came
to a satisfactory conclusion I think I
just gave up when the last dermatologist
he went to was like I think you should
see a real doctor and he's like you're a
dermatologist
this is a scam yeah I just took the
photo for my Personal Collection yeah
I think he just I think when we went
back to the States for Christmas he went
to see like a doctor that was that was
that was the happy ending going back to
the States and now I'm like if I ever
have like a medical emergency am I just
gonna have to book an overnight flight
to the states if it's like that if you
don't if you don't know what it is
because like yeah seems like similar
experience where the doctor just told me
um you should probably see as Doctor
there is that specializes in that and
they don't refer you to to a doctor that
specializes oh just have like a Japanese
friend who can take you to an actual
proper hospital and where you can talk
to an actual Japanese doctor Japanese
doctors are like damn that's crazy
that's crazy
it all sucks for you uh hope you get
better man yeah I wish you good luck
yeah pressing F in the chat for that one
question I can't remember if this is uh
you know when you go to the doctor and
they think it like they probably know
what the problem is
I can't remember if they did this in the
UK because I um do they tell you like
what it like the worst case scenarios of
what it could be as well or do they just
kind of wait until you've gone through
all the normals like stuff and solutions
is that what British doctors do no no
because I'm just thinking because I went
webmdu yeah yeah that's a great some
better explanation do they WebMD you in
the UK or America I feel like that's a
fastest way to freak someone out yeah
yeah so I I uh after the cycling thing
that I did right like it was like eight
days of cycling I had this like pimple
that was like so painful on my ass
no go ahead it's fun it is funny it's so
funny I'm so painful it could be cancer
and it didn't go away for like a while
and I just kind of like it would it
would hurt for a week and then it
wouldn't it would just go and then it
would come back and hurt for a week and
this just kind of happened and it was
like I was [__] stupid because every
week it went I just totally forgot about
it and then I came back I'm like oh yeah
I guess that it still hurts huh all
right so after like two three months of
this I was like all right guess I should
go and check it out and so I go to the
doctor also really [__] awkward that
I should be like he's like what's the
problem I'm like all right this
he's like do you exercise I'm like wow
nine days actually yeah that's the
problem too healthy uh and uh he's he
looks at he goes oh yeah it's pretty
just a uh you know an anti-market
antibacterial thing or whatever
infection yeah it just takes some uh bad
action you'll be fine and I was like oh
cool he's like but it could be herpes
and I was like what I was like why would
you tell me that that's like the
afterthought but it could be her face
yeah I'm like what the [__] how would I
even get it on my ass what the [__] you
have asses
trust me I'm a doctor
nowhere it was like it's it's dude it's
totally this just take this use this
cream it'll be good and then he goes low
chance though I hope he's for real
what the [__] like why would you put
that in my head yeah would you tell me
this I took the antibiotics and I
thought oh my God this isn't get rid of
it I [__] ass herpes
how the [__] did I get that
this must have been from the answer
ain't no way